Boris Johnson likes to position himself
as the people's prime minister there to
deliver brexit but this crowd furious
about the brexit bombshell dropped today
the PM trying to shut down Parliament
for five weeks to stop MP's blocking his
No Deal brexit in a letter to mps mr.
Johnson said he'd end this parliamentary
session in September and starts a new
one on October the 14th we are going to
have a Queen's speech and we're gonna do
it on October the 14th and we've got to
move ahead with a new that is completely
untrue if you look at what we're doing
we're bringing forward a new legislative
programme on crime on hospitals and
making sure that we have the education
funding that we need and there will be
ample time on both sides of that crucial
October the 17th sonnet ample time in
Parliament for MPs to debate Speaker
John Barca with a very different take
this was a constitutional outrage to
stop Parliament debating brexit an
action against democratic process and
the rights of MPs but Jacob Riis morg
returning to Westminster having
delivered mr. Joyce's request to the
Queen insists there's nothing
undemocratic about it so they would know
what they're talking about it's a normal
functioning of our Constitution Her
Majesty order in Parliament beep erodes
but opposition MPs vowing to fight mr.
Johnson tooth and nail suspending
Parliament is not acceptable it's not on
what the Prime Minister is doing is a
sort of smash and grab on our democracy
in order to force through a No Deal exit
from the European Union what's he so
afraid of that he needs to suspend
Parliament to prevent Parliament
discussing these matters
Scottish Tory leader Ruth Davidson's
about to stand down unable to back mr.
Johnson's brexit she delivered success
for previous Tory
pm's but she won't do it for him Tory
opponents much closer to home - in
Westminster the former Chancellor says
he and his colleagues are ready to act
we are determined that Parliament will
show its result to prevent a No Deal
brexit to be perfectly frank a number of
my colleagues would have preferred to
wait until the 30 days that the Prime
Minister has talked about was up and
move in late September that will now not
be possible we will have to try to do
something when Parliament returns next
week they're running short on time but
MPs believe they have options challenges
in the courts emergency legislation in
the Commons setting up an alternative
Parliament and the nuclear option of
passing a vote of no confidence in mr.
Johnson's government this is a prime
minister who has made leaving the EU
do-or-die on October 31st the
cornerstone of his Premiership but many
many people are unhappy with that the
people gathered here and many MPs in
Parliament and his team are determined
that they should not fought his brexit
plan but if MPs do somehow manage to
either stop No Deal brexit or indeed
bring forward a vote of no confidence in
his government then forest Johnson
straight on to his next fight a people
versus the Parliament general election
mr. Johnson sees himself is the people's
Prime Minister prepared to shut MPS out
of parliament if that's what it takes
but the MPs who sit on these benches
don't believe people voted for a No Deal
brexit mr. Johnson must be stopped
whose side are the people really on we
could soon find out in a general
election
Beth Rigby Sky News Westminster